Everybody uh was saying that emotions
are bad for decision-m and our
hypothesis was if emotions are bad why
are we making emotional decisions?
Emotions that the decisions that we make
comes from emotions plus logic logic and
intuition. So if it was something bad
during the evolution, we should have
lost it. And the fact that we are still
making decisions based on emotions shows
that there's an advantage to that. Uh
for us the uh humans, emotions are very
complicated. We can just name a few of
our emotions. But if uh I tell you to or
any other human to describe their
emotions, they can just map it to a a
couple of words but uh that is not
reflect reflecting our uh emotional
status uh in a fair manner. Uh so what
we did was uh was that we studied how
emotions are processed uh in an area
called liic system which is at the base
of the brain. uh basically that area is
responsible for uh processing all of the
emotions and the majority of the
decision making that comes uh in the
mamalian brain
[Music]
nim so good to have you here with me at
the human zero day really looking
forward to having a really thoughtful
conversation together about uh about the
about the space we're in about your own
personal journey your your expertise
your understandings and how you view the
world. So, thank you very much for being
here.
>> Thank you so much, Michael, for having
me and uh it's a pleasure to be in a
show with uh with you as we just were
talking uh you have a very interesting
background and uh it's a pleasure for me
to be with you.
>> Thank you so much. So, so Nema, you
know, it's I want to jump right in
because, you know, you're a pioneer in
the context of emotional AI and and in a
second we'll talk a little bit about
what that means, but with an MD and PhD
in in computational neuroscience, facial
authentication systems, today you're the
founder of Hummingbirds AI. Um, and the
world we're living in is changing very
rapidly. You you've been in the context
of artificial intelligence for for for
quite some time. So this is may perhaps
a rather new phenomena for many many
people but for you it's been a really a
piece of your of your life's work. So
you know tell me a little bit about your
journey up until now leading up to I
guess recently. How did you get into the
space and what has been some of your
core interests here until now?
>> Absolutely. So uh by background I'm a
medical doctor and neuroscientist came
from the biology background. uh and when
I was in medical school fascinated with
uh with the word of uh our brain how
does our brain functions which is uh
still a fascination for me and for many
of us uh and uh basically uh I was uh
going to computer science class in order
to understand how we can model uh the
brain. Uh we started working on a
project uh which was the first project
that brought emotions into machines.
Basically uh everybody uh was saying
that emotions are bad for decision-m and
our hypothesis was if emotions are bad
why are we making emotional decisions?
Emotions that the decisions that we make
comes from emotions plus log logic and
intuition. So if it was something bad
during the evolution, we should have
lost it. And the fact that we are still
making decisions based on emotions shows
that there's an advantage to that. Uh
for us the uh humans, emotions are very
complicated. We can just name a few of
our emotions. But if I tell you to or
any other human to describe their
emotions, they can just map it to a a
couple of words but uh that is not
reflect reflecting our uh emotional
status uh in a fair manner. Uh so what
we did was uh was that we studied how
emotions are processed uh in an area
called liic system which is at the base
of the brain. uh basically that area is
responsible for uh processing all of the
emotions and the majority of the
decision making that comes uh in the
mamalian brain. Uh what we realize is
that all of these components in the lyic
system they are having a certain ro some
of them are in order to exciting other
areas some of them are inhibiting other
areas some of them are responsible for
reinforcement learning. So uh at the end
we created that model we put it in a
controller a simple controller and uh
which we realized that these controllers
that has that emotional decision-m
component first of all they make better
decisions they have less noise they have
less u fluctuations when an external
noise is happening uh and they need less
computation power because when you see a
lion you just run away you don't think
about your different options uh and uh
they uh they are basically faster So
that's that's a perfect scenario for
control engineering where you don't have
access to let's say cloud for uh making
fast decisions. So nowadays they have a
lot of industrial use cases u uh from
robotics to uh to a lot of control
engineering u uh use cases like for
example washing machines when you don't
have access to a lot of computation
resources. uh uh during my uh PhD which
is still ongoing um u is uh uh I was uh
working on small neural networks uh at
the stomach of the crab. So these small
neural networks has only six to seven
neurons but they are very complicated
and they show behaviors that you don't
see them in regular neural networks. So
what we did was uh we uh studied we
created models of that computational
models of that uh in order to create
more efficient uh uh neural networks.
basically a neural network that has tens
of layers, tens of uh or millions of
neurons. You can shrink it down to
smaller scale, more efficient when you
learn from biological systems because
again anything that comes from nature,
anything that comes from biology has
been passing the uh the uh the fight of
the time and uh and it's the most
efficient uh way that uh things could be
could be done. So um again learning from
biology uh
transitioning to a company that we
created called Bell research and then
later on uh hummingbirds AI uh in
hummingbird's AI what we do is uh
learning from how visual perception is
happening which is different from uh the
legacy computer vision models. we were
able to uh shrink those uh uh computer
vision models to be more efficient and
we use that for u automating access to
the computers. Michael you come from the
cyber security world so you know that
the majority of the uh cyber uh or
successful cyber threats are because of
a human uh error uh and the more that we
can we are able to replace humans with
automation uh we are going to have more
security. So what we are going to doing
doing is that we get access to the
camera in real time. We analyze who's in
front of the computer. If that person is
authorized, access would be granted. As
soon as the authorized person leaves or
an unauthorized person comes in front of
the computer, access is blacked out and
the information is protected. Um I can
show you a quick demo. U so the computer
here, the screen is blacked out. In
order to unlock the computer, I just
need to look at it. It's unlocked. I
have access to my information. And then
when I don't look at the computer for a
few seconds, uh the screen is blacked
out and my information is protected. So
I don't need to think about like control
delete uh locking my computer and then
when I come back uh entering my password
or multiffactor authentication. That
being said, we are seeing that u uh we
are going to the AI world uh AGI world
soon and uh there are of course a lot of
concerns about what would be the impact
of AI in cyber security and we think
that uh of course there are a lot of
opportunities but at the same time a lot
of challenges and we are very excited to
explore them and uh creating guards uh
around the negative side of AI to make
sure that AI would be a force for
positive impact for the whole society.
>> Wow. Okay. So, so, so many things that I
want to dive in. I I want to go a little
bit into guacamole ID and and a little
bit into, you know, I read somewhere you
you were discussing sort of the
amygdala's role in facial recognition
and how you're how you and you mentioned
yourself how you're rethinking the
context of computer vision and how do
you provide and how to do sort of next
generation facial recognition. So tell
me a little bit about this technology
and where we're at today because it
seems to me from a lot from you know the
research world this context of facial
recognition has in many areas considered
a almost a solved problem but but I'm
curious to hear how the when you're
fusing it together in the context of
nature
how that changes a little bit the the
game and and what new places we can
innovate here.
>> Yes. Uh so two things to u uh uh set the
foundation. One is that u we have facial
recognition and we have facial matching.
Basically in the facial recognition it's
one to n. You have like n faces. That n
could be millions of faces and you want
to find who is that one face that you
are detecting among those pool of like n
which can be a large number. That's
facial recognition. in the facial
matching with like face ID you have one
face or just a couple of faces and you
want to see if that m face that you are
detecting matches with the face that is
authorized. So the pool is different and
basically the uh the way that you
approach the problem would be different
as well like if u uh in our brain uh we
uh our brain is not designed to do
facial recognition very well. Sometimes
you go to a group of people and you have
a hint that oh I've seen this person but
doing knowing that who that person is
very hard for for our brain but we are
good in facial matching like if I show
you two pictures and then
five months from now ask you who was
this person you can basically recognize
them better. So this is this number one
um and um and um I think it's very u
important to see um there are many
unknown unknowns where in our world um
right now many of the systems that we
have designed like facial recognition
are from the known known like the human
brain or uh or the engineers facial
recognition started from 1950s or 60s.
So in that time they started measuring
like what's the distance between the
eyes eyes and ears um and the nose and
so these key points of the face and then
try to recognize faces based on that. So
it's a mathematical equation that you uh
do and see which uh face is the closest
one to the face that that you are
detecting. But thinking about AI that
would bring uh unknown unknowns or open
doors for us that we didn't know those
relationship existed. It can understand
the faces better than these measurements
like there there are unforeseen
measurements that AI can detect those
relationships way easier than the
computational or mathematical approach
that we are having nowadays. Uh that's
number one and number two is that if you
look at the way that our our brain
functions so we have different modules
right let's say amydala let's say
orbital frontal cortex let's say uh
talamos hypothalamus these these modules
or these models they are each one of
them is responsible for for one thing
and do that thing the best way like for
example the way that uh right now we are
doing LLMs or or rag it's the same Like
we are designing a system that is
specialized in doing one thing, right?
But that thing could be replaced like
you can replace the uh state-ofthe-art
facial recognition models with another
one that a couple of years come uh come
later with with the best one. So when
you design the system, it's going to be
very important to have that modular
design so that you can always replace
the components with the state-of-the-art
models that that are coming in. Uh
talking back back to uh or answering
your question um the way that we u let's
say you go with your significant other
to uh to a large party u and you know
that what she's wearing uh you don't
need to have like her face to recognize
her. You have a holistic view into what
she's wearing, what's her hair color,
what are all of those components. and uh
when uh she's walking among tens of
people or hundreds of people, you are
still able to recognize that person
among that large group. So this is very
different than than uh the facial
recognition system that requires your
face in a frontal and a very specific
manner to be able to do that that
calculations. This is the fundamental uh
differences that in the biological
systems you are having a more holistic
view into uh the shape of the person and
in the facial recognition or more uh
numerical based uh models that more
legacy systems you are very much relying
on uh on just those measurements and uh
uh and the distances uh and the
biometrics of the face.
Okay, that makes makes a ton of sense.
And uh and I can see how through through
thinking about this modular design and
the comparison or the analogy rather to
to the human brain, you can see how
different modules are performing their
core tasks very very well and then by
perfecting on those you can build an
ensemble approach where you where you
utilize the functions of different of
different tuned approaches which makes a
lot of sense. Talk to me a little bit
about about hummingbirds AI and and the
solution because now you're bringing
your research and you're bringing your
your learnings and understandings to
real world applications. You're talking
about security. You're talking about uh
human is the weakest link. We're talking
about humans as you know with the Z
human zero day. Uh so tell me a little
bit about the product more in the and
also in the context of how you're seeing
this play out into the market.
>> Yes. So, so the product by itself is a
software. So, it's a AI based software.
You install it in your computer. Uh, for
now, we have the Windows version of
that. So, it's available on every
Windows computer no matter what kind of
camera you have. One of the limitations
of technologies like facial matching
that you have in your iPhone called Face
ID or in Microsoft Hello uh is that they
require a specific type of cameras and
uh number two is that they only run one
time to grant you access to the device.
So these two shortcomings have some
limitations like you cannot use them in
every laptop and computer. With our
system guacamole you can basically use
that in any laptop and computer in any
Windows computer as long as you have a
camera no matter what kind of camera you
have. So we have been able to bypass
that first limitation to grant access to
a large number of population. Number two
is that because again the computer
vision models are computationally
expensive. If you want to run them,
let's say 30 frames per second in in
your device, you would heat up the
device and um uh that would affect the
battery life, that would affect the
lifetime of your uh device and probably
the user experience. With our system, we
have been able to reduce the computation
power to just a couple of percentage of
uh the CPU. So, it runs locally in the
device. There is no data is traveling
outside. It's like a rolling window that
uh analyzes every frame and go to the
next frame and next frame and next frame
u and so the data stays locally
therefore it's compliant GDPR compliant
hypo compliant you can apply that in the
medical settings or any uh information
any uh sensitive uh area because simply
everything is contained locally in a
closed loop and because uh the the uh
the system wise we are using a very
limited um uh computation power.
Therefore, you can run that
continuously. What that means is that
you have a continuous view about who is
in front of the computer. So, as soon as
the person leaves, you saw that the
computer is blacked out. If another
intruder comes in front of the computer,
we are able to recognize and blocking
access. If you uh enable that feature
and so these functionalities are not
traditionally available in other facial
matching technologies like Face ID and
Microsoft's uh Windows Hello. Uh that
being said uh uh as you can imagine this
is um can be applied to any vertical
like from healthcare to education to
government side to private sector to the
consumer side. So what we figured is
that um um you are coming from the world
of cyber security and you know that uh
the cost of acquisition in the cyber
security world is a lot like with all
the competition that is uh between the
cyber security companies and um the
chief information security officers that
are super busy with their um all the
threats that they are facing every day.
It's going to be very complicated to
have like the sales team that can
address this solution for the
enterprises. So instead of that we said
uh what would be the best approach for
this type of solution is that it sits in
the computer in the chips and therefore
the name guacamole. So every computer
has chips is time for guacamole and the
vision is to basically bring that to
every laptop and computer through
collaborations with the chip makers like
Intel. So that when you buy a new
computer automatically you have this
feature enabled in inside your computer
and basically you can enable that and
use that for regular usage purposes. So
it's a B2P B2C play. At the same time,
if you are an enterprise that would want
to enable this feature, you can easily
uh uh onboard the user. We have the
system to that you can do mass
deployment. We we have the dashboard
that you can uh manage the users. You
can add or new users uh or remove users
and you can basically um use that in
large enterprise settings. And and how
would the onboarding work because it
sounds like you are matching right
there's a matching process so that
you're you're able to identify an
authorized user versus an unauthorized
user. So how how how does that work and
is that something that is adaptive to
the changing circumstances of of a user
or is and and how do you do that if this
is a strictly onrem solution?
>> Absolutely very good question. So um uh
uh first of all the uh the the first
part the onboarding is very easy process
you know the onboarding of face ID that
you rotate your face so that it has the
uh side embeddings and all the angles
but the way that we do it is even
simpler than that. So you register your
face with this uh with the frontal view.
But the thing is that because we we are
having access to the video, we can
capture all the angles through the usage
of the computer. So as soon as we find a
better angle like in this side, we
replace the old embedding with the new
embedding. So the system is learning
continuously from you from your changes.
So if you grow a beard like me or you
change your hair style, the system is
able to recognize and update it
continuously so that you always have the
most uh updated embeddings for for that
specific face. So that means that the
system guacamole is knowing you through
time better and better. Uh the second
part of that is we have two systems. We
have the standalone version which is for
computers that you have a dedicated
computer like a dedicated laptop and
then for the enterprise settings we have
something called the connected version.
Uh in the connected version let's say uh
you are working in a hospital or uh a
police department or any uh uh work that
you would change computers uh in a
frequent manner like if you are a nurse
you are moving between different
computers many computers throughout the
day. So the way that we designed the
system is that you would register your
face in one of the trusted computers in
the network. The uh embeddings, the
biometrics would be extracted, sent
through the server uh to uh through
through the VPN to the server of the
hospital and then through the server to
all of the endpoints that the IT team
assigns to that specific person. That
means that the IT team can assign let's
say these 100 computers to that specific
phase and as you are uh using the
computer and the embeddings get uh
updated there is a heartbeat mechanism
between uh the computers and the server
which broadcastes the updated uh
biometrics to all of the endpoints in a
regular and frequent manner.
>> Amazing. And and so how do you see this
play out from an enterprise perspective
in the context of identity verification?
You know we have different you know
identity has ever since I guess 2015
really has really taken off and has
become a central piece in cyber security
and we see companies like octa emerging
and single sign on approaches. We see
zero trust policies enforced across many
different systems and multiffactor
authentication being deployed and so
this is a you know long and understood
to be a a core problem from a cyber
security perspective. Where does this
fit into the enterprise workflow under
what are the main use cases that you see
and does it live alongside other
solutions in your in your perspective?
Does it replace some of them? How do you
envision this?
>> Absolutely. So we don't replace any of
them. We are a supplement to them. So uh
your uh uh uh traditional and legacy
identity and access management stays uh
the same. So you would do the uh the
authentication the initial au
authentication uh through those systems.
Let me give you an example. Right now if
you are again the same example you are a
nurse you come to uh the the hospital
you go through the uh multiffactor
authentication two-actor authentication
to get access to the computer then you
go to the next computer you have to log
out from this computer go to the next
computer do this process again and then
the next computer do this process again
so uh so basically you have to go
through that process 20 times 30 times
50 times a day in this system you do the
first uh authentication through that
legacy system. So if you were using
multiffactor authentication, you do the
same thing. But as you are moving
between different computers or you go
back to the same computer, anytime that
you are not in front of the computer,
this uh the screen would be protected
with uh with guacamole. Anytime that you
come back, it's going to be unblocked.
So you don't go through that repetitive
multiffactor authentication process. You
do you do that once and the rest of that
would be covered with guacamole. So that
means that you don't go to through that
process over and over again. Uh and uh
uh what was the first question or the
missing part of the question?
>> Well, now that you said this, I I
already have the I'm already thinking
about you know where you're taking me
next. But if you're looking at the
emergence of AI powered threats and so
identity threats, fishing, social
engineering, this landscape is quickly
evolving and shifting. How do you see
that? you you're you're living in the
forefront of AI and I'm curious both how
you see the emergence of social
engineering threats to try to circumvent
these types of solutions. So what are
the most pertinent ones you're seeing
and then how does Hummingbird's AI aim
to resolve some of them through your own
solutions?
>> Absolutely. Very very good question. So
uh again Michael you come from the cyber
security background. I don't come from
the cyber security background. I'm a
very new person to this board uh of
yours but uh you know that in the cyber
security world uh you for the defense
side you have to be right 100% of the
times for the offense side you only need
to be right one time right so there is a
mismatch between the the risk uh uh
between the defense and the offense side
as AI comes it shuffles everything and
it shuffles both defense and offense in
the defense side of course there are new
tools and uh very exciting tools that
are able to help us but at the same time
uh there are many tools that is going to
be used on the offense side. So we are
seeing a lot of new tools and a lot of
new verticals of frauds that they didn't
u uh exist just a couple of years ago
like thinking about how easy it is to do
voice cloning now deep fakes uh very
easy and even the technologies of deep
fakes when it comes to video the
technologies that are available in the
market um are just part of the
technologies that exist but soon there
are going to be more and more
sophisticated ones that are coming out
um I've seen some examples like that. Uh
you can very easily generate u u a
behavior or a video of a person not the
ones that that are available in the
market but uh uh be behind the scenes
that how capable they are and it's going
to be very impossible for regular folks
to understand that this is a real human
or a synthetic human. So uh nowadays in
our fraud we see that somebody is
calling from uh another country and
calls and say oh I'm your doctor or I'm
your banker and um usually like our
older population or more vulnerable
population they are very prone to these
type of attacks and they answer and they
think that yes any anything that anybody
that calls and claims that okay I'm from
this bank that's that's correct. So the
amount of literacy that we have related
to uh uh the fraud is very low. Uh
especially uh I think in most of the
world is is very low. Uh and uh media
literacy is another one like the the
when we see something in social media we
believe that it's true but at the same
time a lot of that you know that that
could be a fraud or or uh another form
of attack. So um so u I think we need
and there's a clear uh uh cry from the
uh community that we need solutions to
simplify makes this more accessible for
everybody to be able to understand that
this is a real human or this is a video
that comes from uh from u AI. So uh when
it comes to deep fake um I I mentioned
um bell research. So uh when uh in 2019
or 2018 uh Facebook saw this challenge
very early on and they created a
challenge with like a million dollar
prize for whoever can detect the face uh
in a very efficient manner. We
participate in that. We didn't win but
we we had a good score and that was the
aha moment to come to uh to the route of
uh humming AI but um I think uh we are
going to have a lot of challenges with
the defects that are coming. uh we are
very much concerned about that. Um I
also started u an organization called
Miami AI club uh u last year u a little
bit over a year ago uh that we figured
that uh many of these technologies could
have a lot of impacts and we haven't
foreseen that impact and we are not
prepared for that impact. So the goal of
this community is to uh basically create
a positive impact through AI and figure
out where AI can be misused and or
appused and then try to build guarders
against that. That being said, deep fake
is one of the uh most important uh
verticals in our focus. So we created
the first communitydriven proposal for
National Institute of Standard and
Technology in the US uh to basically
create guidelines for NIST to how to
address some of these challenges with
defects. For example, in detection uh in
uh labeling u and uh different
strategies in order to mitigate the risk
of deface. We did u a research u a
survey with uh global business leaders
and uh public sector leaders in order to
understand how much they are prepared
for defects and the results we are going
to publish that next month but the
results I'm going to give you a hint uh
the level of that we are prepared is uh
very close to zero we we know that
problem but we are not prepared for
that. So uh I call it like
>> so Nema tell me this is fascinating tell
me let's talk about preparedness. So one
I'm curious you know you've been in the
deep fake space then from 2019 2020 I
remember the publication of the DFDC
challenge and I was following it closely
during my studies at Stanford why so
where were you at when this challenge
came in you were you must have been
thinking to yourself wow this is a
really big problem that should be
addressed and you're you're I mean when
in talking about nature and biology in
the context of humans I mean this is you
know the the mimicking of human behavior
and if not from just the visual but also
the emotional sides. H what are the
relevant solutions in your perspective
detection or otherwise and how did that
meet your own journey and your own
decision-m as an entrepreneur?
>> Absolutely. That's a very good question.
Uh so when um uh we uh faced that
challenge uh one of the biggest uh
problems that we figured was the amount
of the uh computation power that is
needed in order to detect if this video
is uh is a fake or or a real one. Uh
like running these computer vision
models for video analysis is very
expensive and not something that can be
done locally in the device the majority
of the time. So we figured if these
technologies could be having a real
impact for defect detection, it needs to
be very much lightweight and uh
something that can be applied in regular
computers so that we don't rely on the
cloud because if it's on the cloud there
are some complications with that like
for example the cost is too much like
imagine how much expensive would be the
cloud cost of uh of of running all of
the these videos uh on the cloud.
Another one was of course the privacy
security aspect of that the latency all
of that would be some blockers in order
to run these models uh on the cloud. So
that uh was the aha moment to why not
use the belt systems the emotional
systems that we uh created in 2003 2004
because what we learned from those
controller was that the bioinspired ones
they are way more agile way more
lightweight they make better decisions
and they need less computation power so
it makes sense to apply them in this
scenario. So we uh created a system uh
based on the same structure uh uh of the
base of the brain again the lyic system
and if you look at it it does make sense
Daniel Canaman the award-winning uh the
Nobel uh prize winner I think he was in
the Stanford too uh he also mentions
that in his book uh the fast and slow uh
pathways. So in our brain we have that
fast pathway the fight orflight response
when we see a lion we just run away and
then there there is a slow pathway like
when you go to a room at the in a in a
millisecond you have a sensation that oh
this is room feels comfortable or feels
very scary or I should be uh very much
on my toes to to run away or and then
there there are like the slow pathway
you start analyzing things okay who is
in this room what's the color of the
room uh what are the threats that that
I'm that I might face. So that uh fast
and slow pathway is very helpful here
because then you can use the fast
pathway in order to remove a lot of the
scenarios that you would uh uh you you
you are confident that these are very
much fake and you don't need to put a
lot of computation resources into going
into the details of that. And then the
slow pathway when you are seeing that oh
this might be somehow in the gray zone
and somehow I'm feeling halfway and I'm
not uh completely sure. So you have the
luxury of the time and uh more
computation resources in order to
analyze those videos uh in a more
detailed manner. And so if we're looking
into the future a little bit, you know,
four or five years, uh, usually it
wasn't, it didn't seem like to be a long
time, but in today's world, uh, it we're
going to be in a whole different society
in four or five years, looks to be. So
what are the right or relevant solutions
to be fighting these types of AI powered
fishing and threats that could really
undermine, you know, society's ability
to distinguish between what is real and
what is synthetic? what what are the
right approaches in your perspective?
>> Absolutely. So, so what I'm seeing is
that first you you pointed a very good
uh thing that four to five years
nowadays is looking a long time and and
I do agree with you with like the AGI
that is coming artificial general
intelligence and the amount of the u
it's a powerful tool. the more powerful
the a tool could be, it can in the right
hands it can be a good tool and then in
the in the wrong hands it can be uh
damaging to the society. So I think now
uh the good side is behind the defense
side is behind with with AI not even
with AGI and AI is going to make that
worse. So I don't think that we would uh
this is my personal opinion I don't
think that we have enough resources to
defend ourselves for an AGI word. I
think we are uh at the best scenario we
are getting ready for the AI world. So
we need a lot of innovators and a a lot
of uh outside of the box thinkers in
order to come and disrupt things see
things differently and comes up with new
strategies in order to mitigate that
risk. That is a risk that cannot be done
uh or mitig uh or uh be addressed by one
person, one group, one individual or uh
or one uh country or one government. It
requires a lot of uh crossindustry,
crossber uh communications and
collaborations in order to be able to to
mitigate that risk. And I think that uh
with one direction with one solution is
going to be very hard. We need to have
like a syndicate. We need to have like a
group of technology companies working
together in order to uh to be able to
mitigate that risk.
>> And and and that speaks I guess to your
own strategy which you mentioned about
25 minutes ago in regards to glaci
in that you're not fighting or not
you're not try you're not pulling away
from existing solutions. you're a
supplement to the existing solutions.
looking at how do you augment the
already myriad of solutions that exist
but but adding new new ones along the
way that that and and by the way the
demo looked uh very very cool when
you're talking when in the context of
enterprise security humans are the
weakest link h and if we're looking at
the evolution of deep fakes and social
engineering attacks how do you find
security professionals you mentioned
that you did a you're going to release a
you know a survey rather soon but how
how do you see their awareness and their
I guess willingness to innovate to adopt
new solutions to think differently from
before because there have been identity
security tools in the past and there
have been you know email security
solutions up until now um obviously
nobody's monitoring this call that we're
here I I hope that you are you but I
didn't see anything running to verify
that
where are security professionals these
busy CISOs with this problem space
>> I think u the CISOs know the fact that
this this is a new vertical uh what I'm
seeing is that um of course they are
having a lot of threats that are coming
and uh and uh the cyber security world
is becoming um very complic complicated
for for the CISO so I think uh the level
of that they are prepared for this is
not that much. They're hoping for the
best. But this this is a problem that
not only affects the CISOs. This is a
problem that affects the elections. This
is a problem that affects the integrity
of the news media. So it's a
multi-dimensional problem and a problem
that needs to more of the u more of
outside of the CISO people to also
address this problem and try to stop
that. Like for example I know uh that uh
department of justice they are working
on solving this problem right but there
are many cases that they are seeing like
in the courts that uh that uh there are
videos of the teachers that they are not
the teachers but saying something or uh
doing something that is not right. So
imagine how many new cases are going to
the courts and bombarding the the court
system. So it's it's not only the
problem of security but it's a societal
problem that we are going to face and
for that reason I think it's not only a
problem of CISOs but a problem of every
layer of um it's a problem of the boards
it's a problem of every layer of the
executives like if you are CFO you would
need to know what's a deep fake because
we have seen cases that they're drawing
like $25 million from a bank account if
you are um u any person in or any
decision maker in an organization, you
need to be prepared for these attacks.
>> Yep. And I think that we'll we'll remain
curious to see how how the right
solutions get implemented and and what
are the right solutions that really
integrate into the workflow because I
think that what what's going to happen
is that we're going to have to
effectively reinvent a lot of the way
that we've been thinking through digital
communication and digital interaction
and how do you create a layer of trust
in the authenticity of the communication
between people h that is in some level
reliant on automations in the back in
the backbone because our human ability,
the ability of our amygdala to continue
doing what it's doing. Well, it's still
going to be good, but it's just not
going to do what it needs to do because
you'll just look exactly like you. And
so, we weren't primed for that.
>> You you said a key word that is very
important and that's trust. So u trust
that comes from authenticity because
nowadays we are living in a digital
world and soon in the AI world that we
really don't know who we are interacting
with and uh and if you're receiving a
content if you are receiving an email
who is it coming from so I think uh uh
we need to rethink that we need to find
ways to be able to bring trust back to
our communication and you address that
very well we need to make sure that the
humans are real humans we need to make
sure that uh whoever is on the other
side is really who they are. It's not
their deep fake. It's not their somebody
that is impersonating them and uh and
without that we are going to have a lot
of problems. So that is the missing part
of the internet or digital interactions
that we have now.
>> Nema thank you so much. This was a
wonderful conversation and thank you for
the great work you're doing with
hummingbirds AI. I look forward to
keeping in touch and uh thank you for
all the great insights.
>> Thank you so much Matias. It was one of
the best uh podcast experiences. I think
u your smartness, your achievements were
uh resonating. It was like shining
through the conversation and it was a
very uh pleasant experience for me and
I'm glad to be uh this morning with you.
Thank you so